you know
it's kind of a fascinating mystery that
twitter
facebook like all these social networks
free
and it seems like almost none of them
except for youtube
have experimented with removing ads for
money
can you like do you understand that from
uh both economics and the
product perspective it's something that
you know so i teach a course on
digital business model so you say used
to at mit at stanford i'm not quite sure
i'm not
teaching until next spring i'm still
thinking what my course is going to be
but there are a lot of different
business models and we have something
has zero marginal cost
there's a lot of forces especially if
there's any kind of competition that
push
prices down to zero but you can have ad
supported
systems you can bundle things together
you can have volunteer you mentioned
wikipedia there's
donations and i think economists
underestimate the power of volunteerism
and donations
you know national public radio actually
how do you do this podcast how is this
uh
what's the revenue model there's
sponsors at the beginning
and then and people the funny thing is i
tell people
they can it's very i tell them this
timestamp so if you want to skip the
sponsors you will be for free
but the it's funny that a bunch of
people so i read
the the advertisement and a bunch of
people enjoy reading it
and well they may learn something from
it and also from the advertiser's
perspective
those are people who are actually
interested you know like i mean the
example i sometimes get like
i bought a car recently and all of a
sudden all the car ads were like
interesting to me
exactly and then like now that i have
the car like i sort of zone out okay but
that's fine the car companies
they don't really want to be advertising
to me if i'm not going to buy their
product
um so there are a lot of these different
revenue models and you know
it's a little complicated but economic
theory has to do with what the shape of
the demand curve is when it's better to
monetize
it with charging people versus when
you're better off doing advertising
i mean in short on when when the demand
curve is relatively flat and wide
um like generic news and things like
that then you tend to do better with
advertising if it's a good that's only
useful to a small number of people but
they're willing to pay a lot they have a
very high
value for it then you advertising isn't
going to work as well you're better off
charging for it
both of them have some inefficiencies
and then when you get into targeting and
you get these other revenue models it
gets more complicated
but there's some economic theory on it
i also think to be frank there's just a
lot of experimentation that's needed
because
sometimes things are a little
counter-intuitive especially when you
get into
what are called two-sided networks or
platform effects
where um you may grow the market on one
side
and harvest the revenue on the other
side you know facebook tries to get more
and more users
and then they harvest the revenue from
advertising um so that's
another way of kind of thinking about it
is it strange to you that they haven't
experimented
well they are experimenting so i you
know they are doing some experiments
about what the
willingness is for people to pay yeah um
i
i think that when they do the math it's
gonna work out that they still are
better off
with an advertising driven model but um
what about a mix
like this is what youtube is right yes
you
you allow the person to decide the
customer to decide
exactly which model they prefer yeah no
that can work really well you know
and newspapers of course have known this
for a long time the wall street journal
the new york times
they have subscription revenue they also
have advertising revenue
and uh that can that can definitely work
the online is a lot easier to have a
dial that's much more personalized and
everybody can kind of roll their own
mix and i could imagine you know having
a little slider about
how much advertising you want or willing
to take
and if it's done right and it's
incentive compatible it could be a
win-win where where both the content
provider
and the consumer are better off than
they would have been uh before
yeah you know the done right part is uh
is really a good point like with the
jeff bezos and the single click purchase
on amazon
the frictionless yeah effort there if i
could just rant for a second about the
wall street journal all the
newspapers you mentioned is i have to
click
so many times to subscribe to them
that i'm i literally don't subscribe
just because of the number of times i
have to click
i'm totally with you i don't understand
why so many companies make it so hard
i mean another example is when you buy a
new iphone or a new computer whatever
you i feel like okay i'm gonna like lose
an afternoon just like
loading up and getting all my stuff back
and and
for a lot of us that's more of a
deterrent than the price
and if they could you know make it
painless
we'd give them a lot more money so i'm
hoping somebody
listening is working on on making it
more painless for us to buy your
products
if we could just like linger a little
bit on the social
network thing because uh you know
there's this netflix uh
social dilemma yeah no i saw that and
and
tristan harris and company yeah
and you know people's data
people are it's really sensitive and and
social networks are at the core
arguably of uh many of societal
like tension and some of the most
important things happening in society so
it feels like it's important to get this
right
both from a business model perspective
and just like a trust perspective
i i still gotta i mean it just still
feels like
i know there's experimentation going on
it still feels like everyone is afraid
to try
different business models like really
try well i'm worried that
people are afraid to try different
business models i'm also worried that
some of the business models may
lead them to bad choices and
you know danny kahneman talks about
system one and system two sort of like
our reptilian brain that reacts quickly
to what we see
see something interesting we click on it
we retweet it
versus our system two you know our
frontal cortex that's supposed to be
more careful and rational
that really doesn't make as many
decisions as it should
i think there's a tendency for a lot of
these social networks to
really exploit system one are quick
instant reaction make it so we just
click on stuff and pass it on
and not really think carefully about it
and in that system
it tends to be driven by you know
sex violence disgust anger fear
you know these relatively primitive
kinds of emotions maybe they're
important for a lot of purposes
but they're not a great way to organize
a society and most importantly
when you think about this huge amazing
information infrastructure we've had
that's connected
you know billions of brains across the
globe not just we can all
access information but not contribute to
it and share it
arguably the most important thing that
that network should do
is favor truth over falsehoods
and the way it's been designed not
necessarily intentionally
is exactly the opposite my uh my mit
colleagues senator arl
and deb roy and others at mit did a
terrific paper in the cover of science
and they document what we all feared
which is that
lies spread faster than truth on
social networks they looked at a bunch
of tweets and retweets
and they found that false information
was more likely to spread further faster
to more people and why was that it's not
because
people like lies it's because people
like things that are shocking
amazing can you believe this something
that is
not mundane not that something everybody
else already knew
and what are the most unbelievable
things well
lies and so you if you want to find
something unbelievable it's a lot easier
to do that if you're not constrained by
the truth
so they found that the the emotional
valence of
false information was just much higher
it was more likely to be shocking
and therefore more likely to be spread
another interesting thing was that
wasn't necessarily driven by the
algorithms
i know that there are is some evidence
uh you know xenopht tafeki and others
have pointed out in youtube
some of the algorithms unintentionally
were tuned to amplify more extremist
content
but um in the study of twitter that
cenan and deb and others did
they found that even if you took out all
the bots and all the
automated tweets you still had lies
spreading significantly faster
it's just the problems with ourselves
that we just can't resist
passing on the salacious content the
but i also blame the platforms because
you know there's different ways you can
design a platform you can design a
platform
in a way that makes it easy to spread
lies and to retweet and spread things on
or you can kind of put some friction on
that and try to
favor truth i had dinner with jimmy
wales once you know the guy who uh
helped found uh wikipedia
and uh and he he convinced me that look
you know you can make some design
choices
whether it's at facebook or twitter at
wikipedia or
reddit whatever and depending on how you
make those choices
you're more likely or less likely to
have false news create a little bit of
friction like you said
yeah you know that's the uh and so the
friction could be
speeding the truth you know either way
but and i don't totally understand
the truth i love it yeah yeah you know
amplifying it and giving it more credit
and you know like in academia which is
far far from perfect
but you know when someone has an
important discovery it tends to get more
sighted and
people kind of look to it more and sort
of it tends to get amplified a little
bit
so you could try to do that too i don't
know what the silver bullet is but
the meta point is that if we spend time
thinking about it
we can amplify truth over falsehoods and
i'm disappointed
in in the heads of these social networks
that they haven't been successful
or maybe haven't tried as hard to
amplify truth and
part of it going back to what we said
earlier is you know these revenue models
may push them more towards
growing fast spreading information
rapidly getting lots of users
which isn't the same thing as finding
truth
you